c'est un élu de ba payant chose que nous
recevons dont sont faits dès ce matin
bonjour miguel laventure donc je me
réveille autant bonjour la martinique et
l'île de batz payant chance conseiller
exécutif en charge du fonds européen
mais quelle aventure de vives tensions
sont apparues lors de la plénière de
jeudi dernier entre vous et avec yan
monplaisir vice présidents d'assemblée
marine et orbi conseillère en charge du
développement économique des tno si ce
matin le dit après le week-end est ce
que cette tension est un peu retombée au
sein de votre famille politique
écoutez moi je n'ai pas eu de tension
vous avez assisté il ya si vous y étiez
à une interpellation sans fondement nous
le verrons j'espère tout à l'heure de la
part de camarades d'élus deux collègues
qui se sont exprimés avec une vivacité
que j'ai évidemment condamné mais avec
élégance comme d'habitude en appelant
d'ailleurs à la tempérance à
l'apaisement et à la solidarité pour la
piller nos territoires conséquent donc
si la tension est tombée du côté de l'ol
a émergé c'est tant mieux si ça n'est
pas le cas et je renouvelle mes en
invitation à la tempérance au self
control et puis si on doit la volonté de
travailler travailler simplement faire
des incantations et si possible laissez
moi finir et si possible travailler
ensemble c'est à ce prix que la
martinique va avancer
ça ne vaut pas seulement pour cette
circonstance du fonds européen mais sur
tous les sujets parce qu'on a quand même
l'impression que depuis le cycle de
rencontres orchestrées par bpi en
chansons janvier la première conférence
était je me sens bien à la batelière
or on avait quand même les pressions qui
avait déjà quelques pointes de tensions
concernant l'utilisation des fonds
européens
on avait ressenti comme ça de
l'extérieur écoutez moi je suis content
que vous en parliez vous savez que nous
avons pris l'initiative dans ce mois de
mai qui au niveau de l'ensemble de
l'europe est considérée il ya depuis dix
ans comme le moment pour communiquer eh
bien nous avons décidé de mettre un peu
un coup de projecteur sur ce qui se
passe en martinique concernant les fonds
européens
et si vous avez suivi
première information avec notamment la
conférence de presse donnée depuis le 2
mai mais beaucoup de médias le relier
votre média l'a relayé et bien vous avez
vu que nous avons aujourd'hui des
résultats qui sont extrêmement
intéressants et si vous avez suivi la
dernière plénière vous aurez noté que et
bien jeudi dernier il y a eu d'abord un
conseil exécutif pendant lequel une
cinquantaine de dossiers ont été
satisfaits en matière de fonds européens
et pendant la plénière
il y a eu lieu cette nombre de dossiers
emblématiques fondamentaux déterminant
pour l'avenir de la martinique comme par
exemple le très haut débit 140 millions
elles dont les jeunes affiliés à 34
millions d'euros environ permet
d'imaginer qu'elle soit amendée une
information je vous la donne également
des opérations et de concertation au
sein de ba payante on est quand même
important parce que vous êtes au sein
d'une majorité où il ya quand même
certaines crispations un peu partout il
ya jean philo qui crée son pays il ya
six ans c'est le ba payant chance à
noeux sa commence à être assez glatigny
un petit peu ça donne quand même une
image un peu difficile pour la majorité
surtout que claude lise de son côté ben
lui se plaint du fait que la cité ne
fonctionnent pas très très bien ça donne
quoi comme ça renvoie comme image auprès
de la population et et vous n'avez pas
besoin de ma présence pour dire tout ce
que vous venez de lire la choisissait de
faire un édito si vous le voulez si vous
m'invitez c'est pour parler de mes
responsabilités vous allez lui de vous
m'avez introduit politique de premier
plan
là on vous pose de question de temps
alors précisément comment puisque il y
aura des élections dans un an et demi
quelques temps un avis de pouvoir
écouter
laissez moi vous dire mon vécu le vécu
des autres vous l'appréciez comme vous
voulez mon vécu
c'est que je secrétaire général d'une
formation politique s'appelle forces
martiniquaises de progrès jamais vous
n'avez entendu au cou le site trois
années bientôt et demie dire quoi que ce
soit ni sur l'ensemble de la majorité
qui est actuellement dans cette alliance
que nous avons constitué ni sur ba
payant chance nous allons continuer dans
cette voie puisqu'un c'est l'orientation
permanente est toujours bas payant se
battent ou non seulement j'y suis mais
je rappelle que si nous n'y étions pas
il n'y aurait pas eu la vie de moi
soyons clairs et par conséquent une
élection c'est une addition de voix et
par conséquent ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
élus doivent savoir qu'ils le doivent
réciproquement à ceux qui ont participé
et puis deuxième rendez-vous coincé en
train de fret par les jeunes également
plaisir je me sens aujourd'hui dans
celui dans la position de celui qui a
fait le choix de donner à la martinique
une opportunité m'a d'alternance et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui et bien et compris
sous les fonds européens je rappelle que
les était consommée à seulement 2 %
lorsque nous sommes arrivés au 1er
janvier 2016 quand aujourd'hui nous
avons quelque chose suivant les fonds
puissent y en a plusieurs qui va entre
50 et 60 pouces je rappelle que nous
avons tenu tous les rendez vous qui
était fixée c'est la seule organisation
les fonds européens qui ont une
obligation de résultat vous savez vous
31 décembre ont droit a atteint quelques
objectifs si on a autant un dégagement
un dégagement d'office d'un donc on ne
discute même pas avec vous et vous
perdez de l'argent
nous avons tenu le 31 décembre 2015 2016
31 décembre 2017 31 décembre 2018 je
crois pouvoir dire que les choses
s'engage bien l'art ou 2019 et par
conséquent aujourd'hui notre objectif
c'est véritablement de faire en sorte
que ce pourquoi nous avons été vus
remercier les électeurs et bien soit
satisfait expliquez-nous pourquoi cette
image persiste message est un message
d'ordre économique selon laquelle la ccm
ne jouent pas le jeu
concernant le financement des porteurs
de projets en martinique des chefs
d'entreprise qui se disent on ne
comprend pas ce qui se passe là bas on
ne nous écoute pas et deux sont en train
de crever la bouche grande ouverte
c'est juste une vague impression ce sont
des idées négatives persistantes
je ne sais pas si c'est vous qui avez
quelques rêves ou en quelqu'un quelques
noms mais n'hésiteront pas à chaque fois
notre domaine les pailles je vous
interromps pas dans vos questions mais
interrompu pas dans mes réponses
je ne sais pas si c'est vous qui avez il
ya quelques visions nocturnes qui vous
amène à dire 7 nombre de choses le matin
mais le constat que je fais je vous ai
donné les chiffres c'est que nous sommes
au rendez vous des obligations qui sont
les nôtres
le constat que je fais c'est que nous
avons aujourd'hui des équipes qui
travaillent même si évidemment chacun
pourrait espérer pour son propre but
aller plus vite mais je veux rappeler
qu'il y a des rêves qui sont des règles
légales qui sont des contraintes si on
ne les respecte pas on est durement
sanctionné sous le nom financière je dis
on c'est le porteur de projet en même
temps elle a cité m
et puis je veux également dire que
aujourd'hui l'attention que nous portons
aux chefs d'entreprise elle et à tous
les niveaux qu'il soit puissant cran
avec un pignon sur rue ou qu'ils soient
en émergence aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est qu'il fera beaucoup dans
l'exécution que nous avons c'est que
précisément les petits porteurs de
projets dans tous les domaines de
l'agriculture je sais que c'est un
secteur qui vous intéressent l'anti zana
le commerce le tourisme et bien nous
donnons leur chance à un certain nombre
de petits porteurs et et en particulier
on our à noter que nous avons pris
l'initiative de donner je dirais
quelques respirations supplémentaire au
crayon des dispositifs en créant jérémy
justement créances et 5 millions d'euros
en criant laissez moi finir en créant
des opportunités pour enchanter nombre
de petits porteurs d'avoir enfin un
accompagnement et on voit le résultat
le projet réunit 35 millions d'euros
susceptible de mobiliser pour aider les
entreprises adoptant plénière est un peu
plus de noms qui s'entrechoquent avec un
autre dispositif capital investissement
c'est ça qui a créé la tension de jeudi
dernier alors vous avez raison de
rappeler qu'il ya une chronologie monte
il vous reste pour par des gardes et les
mois vous avez raison de rappeler que
votre serviteur en tant que conseiller
en charge des questions financières et
pas seulement des fonds européens a pris
l'initiative avec le président marie
jeanne qui évidemment est le responsable
ultime de mettre en place un fonds
d'investissement un fonds de capital
investissement pour aider les petits
projets et les choses ont bien avancé
elles sont elles étaient sous le point
d'aboutir ce qu'il y a eu une nouvelle
initiative je vais vite mais vous savez
rien ne se fait à coups de baguette
magique et je vous dis très
le mans très simplement aujourd'hui il
faut bien sûr travaillé qu'il ya un
savoir faire qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
et que si on se contente simplement
d'être dans les cotations
on n'y arrive pas deuxième conclusion je
veux parler simplement de l'ensemble de
ceux qui imaginent que les fonds
européens et bien si simplement allongé
la main attrapez l'argent et faire
l'europe ne fonctionne pas comme ça il
faut savoir monter les dossiers il faut
savoir les montées il faut respecter les
chronologies de d'étape
il faut faire en sorte que quand on vous
demande estimant quand on vous demande
des papiers quand on vous demande des
itinéraires vous demande de faire le job
et bien que vous soyez au rendez vous
sinon et bien évidemment on pleurniche
merci miguel laventure et puis mes
visions nocturnes et les conceptions de
la vie nocturne et commence à leur
mercie miguel laventure conseil exécutif
en charge des fonds européens
les visionner j'aime assez vous remercie
de m'avoir offert cette opportunité par
livrer